the grazing animals must struggle  mightily in search of a few blades of  grass many elk grow weak as winter drags  on but someone else grows strong the  wolf thrives in winter highly  intelligent and social creatures they  often show deep affection for one  another their intense family ties also  make them a deadly hunting unit once  completely exterminated from the park  gray wolves were reintroduced in 1995  and have become a vital player in the  parks ecosystem eagerly chasing a big  bowl elk the wolf is in its element in  Yellowstone  [Music]  [Music]  but this bowl didn't earn his rack by  being anyone's food  he finds refuge in the frigid lamar  river where the wolves cannot follow and  aims his impressive racket then  [Music]  but another dinner awaits as the rest of  the pack announces they've taken a  weakened bison during the night and  there's more than enough to go around  with such a large pack to feed they need  to hunt successfully nearly every day  [Music]